We've got four scenarios
right over here.
In each scenario, we
have a hydroxide anion.
And then, we have
another molecule.
And right over
here, this molecule,
this is a bromomethane.
So it's a bromo group
attached to a carbon.
And this carbon isn't
attached to any other carbons.
It's only attached
to other hydrogens.
So carbon like this we
call a primer-- actually,
not a primer.
We call this a
methylcarbon because it
is attached to no other carbons.
Now, let's think about
this right over here.
What's the difference between
this scenario and that one?
We still have our
hydroxide anion.
We still have the bromo group.
But now this carbon is
attached to another carbon.
So this right over here
is a primary carbon.
It's attached to
one other carbon.
And I think you
see a pattern here.
What about this one?
Well, this carbon right over
here is a secondary carbon.
It's attached to
2 other carbons.
And then, finally, this
carbon right over here
is a tertiary carbon.
It's attached to
3 other carbons.
And as we'll see in a
few seconds, the fact
that it has these other carbons
and that these other carbons
kind of might block some
or all of the reaction,
it will change what
actually goes on.
So let's go, first, to the
first scenario right over here.
We have a hydroxide anion.
We've already seen
that a hydroxide anion
is a decent nucleophile.
So this right over
here is a nucleophile.
And bromine is a
decent leaving group.
And so assuming that it's
in a appropriate solution--
we'll cover that
in future videos--
you could imagine
that one of these,
if this hydroxide kind of
bumps into this bromomethane
in just the right way, that
this pair right over here
could form a bond
with this carbon.
And just as that is happening,
essentially the carbon
is gaining half of
a bond, which is
kind of the equivalent
of a electron charge.
So then, this bromine could
take away this entire pair.
Instead of just kind of
sharing it and having
the equivalent of 1 electron
charge from this pair,
it has both of them.
And then, it'll become
the bromide anion.
And we've already
seen that before.
That is an Sn2 reaction.
It's a nucleophilic substitution
where both reactants--
so the nucleophile and
the leaving group--
are involved in the
rate-determining step.
And this will actually
be quite fast.
Right over here.
Now, let's look over here.
The only difference--
we already said--
is the existence of this CH3.
Now, even though we've
drawn it, written it down,
CH3, when it's written down,
doesn't look a lot bigger
than an H. Remember,
CH3-- I mean,
this is roughly the size of
this thing right over here.
So if we were to actually draw
it out with the hydrogen bonds,
this is quite large.
And remember-- in chemistry
and in organic chemistry--
we always draw these
neat and clean reactions,
but that's not the way
it happens in real life.
These things are all
bumping in a solution
and bumping from
every direction.
And depending on how they bump
and their relative energies,
the bonds, the reactions
may or may not happen.
And so in this scenario,
this fairly big part
of this molecule might
block the approach
of a hydroxide anion
coming from that direction.
The good thing
is-- well, I guess,
if you view Sn2
reactions as good--
is that there's still other
directions that it can come in
from.
So you could still
see the Sn2 reaction,
but it's going to
be a bit slower.
So maybe here, we could write
a bit slower, but still fast.
Now, let's think
about this scenario.
And once again, I think you
can see where it's going.
The only difference now is
it's the secondary carbon.
We have these two groups here.
And remember, these are
much larger than the way
that I've drawn it.
You have a carbon
attached to 3 hydrogens.
So now we're blocking
from two directions.
So once again, you can still
have your Sn2 reaction,
but it's going to
happen a lot slower.
So now, you're going to
have a slow Sn2 reaction.
And now, finally,
what's happening here?
Well, here, this
entire side is blocked.
You have a CH3, CH3, CH3.
This hydroxide anion isn't
going to be able to get through.
It is being hindered.
So here we have no Sn2.
Now, you might be saying,
wait, why didn't it
come from the other end?
Well, remember Sn2 reactions--
the nucleophile is attacking
from one side, and
the leaving group
is leaving from the other.
If the nucleophile were
coming in from here,
the leaving group would have
trouble leaving from there.
It wouldn't work out as well.
Sn2, nucleophile from one side,
leaving group from the other.
Now, the only thing that could
reasonably happen here-- and it
is reasonable.
And actually, we've
even seen it when
we looked at Sn1 reactions--
is maybe the leaving
group leaves first.
And actually, the tertiary
carbon is bad for the Sn2,
but it's good for having
a stable carbocation.
If this bromine takes that
pair and becomes bromide,
then this becomes a
carbocation, which
will be reasonably stable
because that positive charge
can kind of be spread
amongst its brothers.
And then, at that point, it's
not crazy for a nucleophile.
And you could even have
a weaker nucleophile
than the hydroxide anion to come
in and actually form a bond.
Now, this general
idea that we're
talking about in this video--
this idea that a reaction
happening or not happening
because of three dimensions
of something hindering
the reaction-- this
is called steric hindrance.
Steric refers to what's
happening in three dimensions--
the size and shape of molecules.
Hindrance is that that
three-dimensional size
and shape is hindering
the reaction.
So the steric hindrance is
greatest right over here,
and it's the least right over
here for the Sn2 reaction.